sur les douze mille sept cents migrants
laissées sans abri par l' incendie qui a
détruit le camp de moria 9000 ont trouvé
refuge sous ces tentes un campement
provisoire a été installé à la hâte dans
un ancien champ de tir à 3 km du port de
mytilène chef lieu de l'île de lesbos
après avoir campé de nombreux jours au
bord de la route est à même l'asphalté
les demandeurs d'asile ont pu finalement
rejoindre ce camp provisoire mais les
conditions de vie à l'image du campement
incendie de moria ils sont très
difficiles
les migrants disent manquer de tout et
son contrat attendre de longues heures
devant les supermarchés de l'île pour
pouvoir se ravitailler
depuis que nous nous sommes installés
dans le nouveau camp nous n'avons qu'un
repas par jour il n'y a pas d'eau dans
les douches et les toilettes et il ne
nous donne une bouteille d'eau minérale
par personne je suis en grèce depuis un
long moment depuis un an et trois mois
j'étais à moriat qui était un camp
meilleur que celui ci
ce lieu est un enfer il n'y a pas de
toilettes parfois on doit vivre trois ou
quatre jours sans toilettes ils nous
donnent à manger une fois par jour
si au moins ils le faisaient l'après
midi ce serait bien mais il nous donne à
manger à 5 heures
c'est très difficile de rester ici c'est
vraiment difficile et stressant
l'endroit est très froid au moins à
moriat les conditions étaient meilleures
parce qu'il y avait plus d'enfants
c'est vraiment difficile le haut
commissariat des nations unies pour les
réfugiés indique de son côté qu'il
soutient ce nouveau camp comme solution
provisoire mais met en garde contre la
pérennisation d'une installation
d'urgence le nouveau site fonctionne
désormais en tant que centre
d'hébergement d'urgence avec l'objectif
de répondre aux besoins immédiats et
urgents des personnes affectées par les
incendies à moriat en termes d'abris de
vivres d'eau de soins médicaux et
d'installations d'assainissement
le hcr soutient son utilisation en tant
que solution temporaire mais prévient
que ce qui peut convenir en termes
d'abris et de services durant des
situations d'urgence n'est pas approprié
sur le long terme
les autorités grecques n'ont pas encore
clarifié l'objectif de ce site
à plus long terme tout demandeur d'asile
est soumis à un test pour le coc vite 19
à l'entrée du camp plus de 200 cas de
coronavirus ont été détectés selon les
derniers chiffres communiqués par le
ministère grec des migrations les camps
de migrants installés en grèce sont
confinés depuis la mi mars à cause de la
pandémie
le hcr et des ong ne cessent de
protester contre cette mesure alors que
le déconfinement dans le reste du pays a
commencé début mai